5 25 on your Friday morning got some
good news and some bad news for your
Labor Day weekend out of town travel on
the I-15 let's start with the good news
this is for the Southbound 15 past Prim
south of the nipton Road exit with the
California Department of Transportation
Caltrans has suspended emergency Bridge
repair work that had a couple of lanes
blocked Caltrans tweeting that a
moratorium for the Labor Day holiday
started this morning will last until
next Tuesday at 6 00 p.m unless there's
an emergency now the bad news this is
for both North and Southbound 15 on your
way to or from Mesquite Justin Hopkins
from the Nevada Department of
Transportation we have that single lane
closure that's in effect in a
semi-permanent fashion we're doing some
trenching work there laying some Fiber
Optic Cables for a smart traffic system
and unfortunately even if we wanted to
we couldn't move that barrier because
there's a four foot hole in the road the
two mile or so lane closures expected to
really back up traffic during the days
we're not suggesting making that trip
either super early in the morning or
much later in the day now to the
Southbound 15 lane closure it's much
shorter it's only about 1500 feet the
problem that we see is that it's up an
incline so if you get stuck behind a
truck that's going 20 miles an hour
taking a while to accelerate that can
cause backup
so everyone at the Nevada Department of
Transportation as well as law
enforcement everywhere urging you to be
patient anywhere you're driving maybe
these heads-ups will maybe prevent Road
raging an already unfortunate situation
and please don't be that guy
who thinks that driving on the shoulder
is a good idea it's not buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone you
can join the driving to Crazy
conversation at traffic eight at
eightnewsnow.com